Why isn't he picking up right now?
What happened?
-Kotona's in danger.
-Danger how?
I don't know,
but some weirdois following her.
-Just hurry.
-Okay.
-Drop me off here.
-Sure!
Will you try contacting Haru?
Sure. I'll try looking for her too.
Kotona!
Stop it!
Kotona?
Kotona!
Kotona...
Don't worry, you're fine.
We'll call an ambulance.
What happened?
Haru, she was stabbed by someone.
Kotona!
Haru, you shouldn't move her!
Let's call an ambulance!
Shut up!Be quiet! What were you doing?
-I...
-I'm taking her to the hospital.
Haru!
Dammit!
Haru, don't!
Haru!
Where the heck are we?
-And what's up with this outfit?
-Yeah.
-Kotona's gone!
-That's right. Kotona!
Where's Kotona?
Haru, your phone!
Right!
This is...
a compass.
What's going on?